(music finishing)
(audience applauds)
- All right y'all.
I want to finish up with
something uplifting and cool
I found scrolling social media,
this is "What I'm Liking".
(band plays)
(audience cheers)
A New York artist is incorporating
one of the earth's most
quintessential elements
into his paintings
and the results are not only beautiful,
the pieces actually have
another layer of meaning,
particularly as we continue
to celebrate Black History Month.
Khari collects water from historic sites,
such as where the first slave
ship sailed into America,
or along the rivers, where Harriet Tubman
helped slaves escape.
He then uses the liquid he
collects for his artwork.
We have him on the line right now
watching on NBC Four New York to explain.
What's up, Khari?
(audience cheers)
- Hey.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my gosh.
It's so beautiful where you are.
I love that that's where
you go to work every day.
That's so cool.
So how did you come up with this idea?
- [Khari] Yeah, so it
really started off in 2020
during the summer when they
led up on the restrictions
a little bit.
So, I was out doing a
residency in California.
I really had a good time out there
and I was doing some work.
And the work I do,
I'm already doing a lot
of research on history
and some of the connections to history,
especially for black people.
So, the ocean always came up.
And I was right next to the Pacific Ocean,
so I was like, "You know what?
I can use some of this ocean water
directly in my paintings."
And so I took some and
put 'em in the painting
and I was like, "Oh, this, this saltwater
changes the material."
So...
- [Kelly Clarkson] Hmm.
- That means I could go
to different locations
and different places
and have all types of different histories.
And so I went out, went to
a lot of different places,
started using them and putting
them directly in the painting
or in the materials and then
just painting with them.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my gosh.
It's incredible.
(audience applauds)
You are so gifted.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. What have you
learned from this project?
- [Khari] I've learned so much.
I've, I'm right now
using 11 different places
in terms of all of my
paintings, including, you know,
you named one, from Jamestown, Virginia,
where the first slave ship
came to United States.
So with that, it's been amazing.
And even though I'm doing like
an abstract and figuration,
a lot of this stuff all
comes back down to like,
we're all made up of water,
we're all bodies of water moving around,
so everybody is connected through water.
So, you know, water is so important
to just my practice as well
as just everybody living.
(audience applauds)
- It's so beautiful.
Thank you so much, Khari.
I love your work.
- Thank you, thank you.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience cheers)
- [Khari] Amazing.
- That's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen Makers, the G2,
the Go-To Pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable people
bringing beauty and meaning
to the world just like you,
so they're gonna be writin' you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
Oh wow. I was not expecting that.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Absolutely.
Please keep inspiring all of us.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
And thank you to all of
our guests this hour,
Anthony Mackie, Madison Bailey,
and all the women from Escape and SWV.
What a great show, y'all.
Have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.